hey what's up this is John Delaney with
Ramsey solutions so world's a mess
world's a mess the new social media the
streets it's a mess and here's the deal
I got a lot of degrees I've been around
a lot of smart people I got a lot of
information but I don't have a lot of
experiences that clue means to what
somebody else is working through right
now so what I want to do in this next
video is I want to model what shutting
my mouth looks like I want to model what
listening looks like I want to model
what's talking to somebody who is a
pastor in my neighborhood who hears
things experiences things and sees
things differently than me has to teach
me about the sidewalk they walk on every
day the people who they lead the
sidewalk they welcome every day that
also happens to be the sidewalk my kids
play on every day and we live in the
same neighborhood and we're having two
different parallel experiences my goal
with this video is to model what
listening and shutting up looks like my
goal is to model what humility and
submission looks like my goal is for you
to feel like you're eavesdropping on a
conversation between two dudes who live
and work in the same neighborhood but
who have radically different experiences
so come listen into my conversation with
dr. John Faison I'm gonna be as
vulnerable as I can and I wanna be as
open as I can and I want to talk to a
guy who your church is in my
neighborhood I rent a house in your
neighborhood I can't afford to buy a
house in the neighborhood but I rent
house around the corner from your church
and so I want to come to you as a guy
who lives in a church and in a
neighborhood where you pastor a church
and say a few miles down the street from
my house like buildings are on fire
literally and a couple of miles from my
house where my kids are playing there
are shattered windows and I don't fully
understand it and so my default setting
is to race to this to the stats and to
race to
in more information and especially to
distance myself from this so can you put
a perspective that what you were
experiencing as a pastor in my
neighborhood sure you you rent a house
near Ned Hill mm-hmm
you you cannot approach moments like
this a historically that's exactly right
these moments are not isolated things
did not just happen and people woke up
one day and just responded
there's a significant sequence of events
that have led to this place what you are
experiencing in Nashville and other
cities across the nation is a boiling
point
it is a bubbling over it is a response
to accumulated repetitive cyclical and
systemic trauma right it's what you see
it shows a microcosm of that
interestingly enough we were founded in
1889 in our church churches about 131
years old 1880 1989 we know Neil's house
before 1994 we were founded in 1889 the
place called unit Tennessee now Eunice
it's between Antioch and the airport
okay it's if you drive I think
Murfreesboro Road you drive down if you
blink you'll miss Yuna okay found it
there but in 1956 we moved to Edgehill
and we moved to NGO because in 1956 NGO
was an affluent african-american area
predominately african-american area
black doctors black Dennis black
attorneys engineers funeral home owners
entrepreneurs you name it really kind of
settled in Edgehill now as Hill was
built by the descendants of the slaves
who built for negly huh okay yeah it
chill is the area where their
descendants settle 30s 40s and 50s
becomes an effluent african-american
area inter you see me moving around I
didn't drive through Edgehill now that
look like that doesn't look like that
well again series of events okay 50s
affluent african-american neighborhood
kinda
a hub of african-american life from
their time inter urban renewal mm-hmm
what'd they take
highway 65 and cut through I mean right
through like me
enter gentrification enter hope six the
federal approach to public housing when
they would take concentrated pockets of
poverty and in court on them in one
particular area cutting them off from
resources access and everything else hmm
all the time the the the spot flips
white flight suburbanization mm-hmm and
what wasn't
affluent african-american neighborhood
it becomes the hood mm very quickly 60
70s this is where it happened are you
talking about ten years I've lived yeah
that take long didn't take long at all
crime goes up education levels drop
access unemployment increases and there
was a time 70s 80s and 90s when you went
to Belmont well you went to Vanderbilt
and as a freshman there in freshman
orientation they told you don't go at
you stay at you they told me the house
the neighborhood that I'm on now which
is a couple streets off the 12th south
mm-hmm ten years ago yeah you did not
ride your bike there you didn't take
your kids to play at the park there 60
70s all the way to about 2005 is what it
was Nashville is one of the cities in
America that responded quickly from the
housing bubble that burst in 2008 okay
all across the nation 2008 occurred
depression recession whatever you want
to call it
Nashville was one of the cities that
quickly responded and recover well
there's no wonder why it happened in
these areas you had a lot of black
renters during its our long-term renters
so he didn't own their lane mm-hmm well
Nashville recovered in the housing
market by taking a lot of the properties
that housed black folks in ATO tearing
them that of these registers on it just
so fast-forward 2000
20 our church sits on the fault line of
gentrification in their geo if you stand
in front of our interests this side you
see public house this side you see
$750,000 tall and skinnies two on one
lot this lot isn't even a point three of
an acre and you got one point five
million dollars of property yeah on it
now these worlds have collided operate
right next to each other but they never
touch see just because you're close
doesn't mean you're in a community
proximity doesn't create community just
because we're close doesn't mean we're
close right so these worlds kind of
function and operate separately but the
ties become the sociological responses
to what's happening around us right
they built a police precinct in our area
in 2014 because they wanted to protect
the citizens where would the police in
the 70s the 80s in the 90 day weren't
around hmm because they were a group of
citizens that weren't deemed worthy of
protection hmm now that's just a
microcosm that's just that's that is a
small zooming but more community but
this is not this is not the what I would
call the narrative which is this over
dramatization of hey I recognize that
400 years ago 600 goes bad stuff happen
mm-hmm at some point we gotta move on
guys right you're talking about you're
talking about people who were old enough
to have lived through the entire cycle
and are still there yes my next-door
neighbor
I call him a tall and skinny holdout man
he's awesome he is awesome but his house
is about 650 square feet next to next to
next to next to right and he's probably
85 years old well in that timeline he's
seen the entire loop and just seeing his
community slowly piece by piece
disappear he's lost his neighbors and
he's been encouraged implicitly he
should probably go he's lost his friends
he's lost his community he's probably on
a fixed income
that sets his budget to be a certain
amount for utilities a certain amount
for this sitting around for that well a
lot of those folks particularly elderly
they don't run their lights during the
daytime they open up they open the
windows and let Sun it when you put up
castles next to them you block their
sunlight which means you've raised their
utility bill they have to run their
electricity now in the data what you
messes with their but and you have
predatory Realtors who come around and
put things on the door and knock and
harass them saying them did you need to
sell your house and they're giving them
numbers that I'm from Texas that Real
Estate's way cheaper but there they put
numbers in front of some of these that
are better half the value of course but
they're still numbers that I never seen
before
of course well these these folks built
their houses in the 60s 70s some even
50s for $80,000 yeah well are 60 or 40
or 30,000 or 60/40 else but they're
being offered one hundred and seventy
five thousand one hundred and fifty
thousand well if you don't know that
your land alone is worth 321
you could be taken yeah so one of our
missions as our church in that
particularly our CDC is to help educate
folks on what they have giving them real
real real time numbers so that they can
make real time legitimate decisions and
not be forced and rushed out based upon
these predatory kind of kind of kind of
kind of moments all of this history is
cumulative we're back so when a person
gets pulled over in 2020 when you get
pulled over you have a certain
expectation on a certain response to
those lights well I have you pulled over
I have a certain expectation in response
to those lights right my tension level
increases I have to be very measured and
strategic with how I respond to the
officer my kids we have a routine I mean
we legit have a protocol that when they
are pulled over they are to call me and
leave me on speaker yeah put the phone
there so the conversation can be
recorded guys their hands have to be on
the 10 and the two right and you say yes
sir and no sir
when they ask for license and
registration you communicate to the
officer the registration is in my glove
compartment I'm going to reach in my
glove compartment is that okay then you
reach in and grab what you need you
share and at the whole time you are
right here always respectful always you
know because that that that's the talk
we call in our commute of course that's
the talk you got to have to keep your
children life and even then you're not
guaranteed right they'll come over right
George Floyd was doing everything the
police told him that's right
he followed every instruction he
followed every requirement he was
unfairly harassed regarding a $20 bill
and he's dead today after having done
the right thing now let's retire oh no
bunch of different bunch of the right
let's talk cumulative effects we've seen
this over and over and over again right
and in most cases if not all officers
who use unfair responses officers who
use excessive force officers who take
unarmed lives a black folks if they get
arrested they don't get charged mmm
doesn't happen hmm Mike Vick for
dogfighting has served more time than
prolific police officers who have killed
on on blanket yeah all together
you served 23 bucks people are tired
their time people are exhausted I'm
saying the same thing over and over and
over again
and we're tired of people seeing this as
isolated incidents and not as a systemic
issue right and so this happened we're
already under tension because of the
pandemic and which is disproportionately
affecting under Allen and I wish I had
time do you know that we don't have to
happen yeah yeah but the accumulated
trauma over time people are sick and
tired
and this moment became kind of a
paradigm in a picture of that moment and
so you get protests and you get
responses that you cannot control and
predict its dr. kay dr. king told us
riot is the language of the unhurt hmm
when you won't hear me when I've been
telling you that this is unfair and
talking about this and having
conversations
then maybe I'll do something to get your
attention I win it and that's what you
see with the protest protest itself is
designed to be disruption that's right
it's designed to bring attention to
areas and issues that we're refusing to
discuss so protest is as American as
apple pie
absolutely it's the country's built on a
protest it's we are protest nation we
dumped tea in the harbor we just have a
problem with desert that's how you
should yeah that's how you should we
want to bring attention and shine light
on inequities within our own selves as a
nation we we struggle with those
responses so what we do is we demonize
those who protest and that's what you
hear from about looting and rioting and
all these other things well let's talk
about looting and right the data we're
seeing data is important it's not the
whole story but it's it's a good portion
that's important not the data that makes
me feel better about my position after
the data shows us that a lot of the
looting and the rioting are coming from
outside actors oh yeah not the people
who organized the protest not the folks
who were present in the middle of this
mm-hmm so you have those who are pimping
the protests mmm for their own
self-aggrandizement for their own
outlandish agendas what protesters are
being blamed for it
here's my issue if you have a problem
with protest miss me with your critique
of protest violence if you have been
silent on police bother if you had
nothing to say about a man having his
life squares out of his body for eight
plus minutes
nobody buzz nobody move it's recorded
you if you had no issue with that then
you don't get to critique how protesters
are spa you as we say here often like
you don't get a vote and you don't you
don't get to you don't get to you know
you don't get to violate me and then
call foul when I respond okay
you don't get to do that yes you give me
a remarkable perspective on my
neighborhood this isn't some academic
exercise these or a lot kids play and
you give me a picture of the community
that I live in that I didn't know and
you also said we a lot so in this next
video we're going to talk about I
because I want to hear about the guy
who's being asked to carry stuff for his
kids and for his wife and for his
community I am glad you're here this is
dr. John Delaney with Ramsey Network
check out the next video and we'll see
you soon